it's an odd feature of love that some of
our most romantic moments can include
the following scenarios being with a
lover who lives a whole continent away
from us and can never move to be closer
an infatuation with a lover who is
married to somebody else and has no will
ever to leave them a romance with
someone dying of a disease that will
kill them within a matter of months a
crush on someone at the library who we
never talked to yet think of obsessively
even when it turns out they have a
partner oh the last days of holiday
romance before we have to take a
grueling 12-hour flight back
what unites all these situations is an
external obstacle to love which
paradoxically serves to make our desire
more intense we might suppose that our
love would be strong in spite of the
challenges but the situation is weirder
than this our love is strong precisely
because a proper relationship is not
possible in the real world because love
is fated to be in some way unrequited or
incomplete people stuck in these
unrequited situations can garner a lot
of sympathy and seem like the natural
friends of true love but they tend to be
no such things
they are timid visitors to the land of
love who have carefully chosen
situations which will prevent them from
ever taking up or permanent residence
they are self saboteurs who would rather
be in control of a sad situation than
half out of control of happy one they
have carefully made sure that there is
no chance either to disappoint or to be
disappointed it is the external obstacle
that gives them the security to
surrender themselves totally to feelings
that they would keep well at
if miraculously the obstacle were to be
removed to feel a lot for someone who is
available is an emotionally highly
flamable requirement the possibilities
for getting hurt are enormous we might
learn to trust a lover over many years
and then promptly find that they decided
to leave us or died in the night we
couldn't survive our defenses mask to
gelatinous and insecure in interior we
would have given them the keys to our
self-confidence and direction and would
struggle after so long to know how to
carry on not all of us have the
psychological histories that make us
robust enough to dare to enter
situations where mutual trust is a risk
that we can dare to endure day to day we
may have been let down too badly as
children perhaps a parent left or
humiliated us and we are at some level
therefore profoundly determined never
again to surrender in the true sense to
another person you don't put it that way
to ourselves of course we're most likely
not even aware of the pattern were
involved in we just feel very in love
whenever someone happens to reside very
far away while we report that a person
who has an apartment round the corner is
truly very boring and not that sexy it
sounds for a time before you can start
to see the pattern
probably visible the true challenge of
relationships is not to fall in love
with someone who may never want to see
us again it is to accept the far more
interesting and truly heroic challenge
of falling in love with someone who
isn't dying isn't stationed in the
Arctic or married to somebody else
someone who'd have no objection to
seeing us pretty much all the time
impossible situations feel so romantic
not because we have found a soulmate but
because the absence of risk has loosened
our hearts but we should with time more
fairly learn to dare to turn our amorous
attentions to that deeply dangerous
threatening but ultimately rewarding
character the person we know the person
who likes us a lot and a person who's
available all the time now that would be
truly romantic to learn more about love
try our book on how to find love which
explains why we have the types we do